c'est le calme avant la ruée vers les
vendanges
malgré ces quelques jours de vacances
christophe n'est jamais très loin de son
vignoble avec un oeil sur les pieds de
vigne et l'autre sur la météo
alors comment se porte la vigne cette
année elle se portera très bien
merveilleusement bien d'ailleurs peu de
pression maladie donc les vignerons sont
bien décontracté ça peut se ressentir
et puis et puis on avait besoin 2012
était un très bon millésime 2013 un peu
moins surtout quantitativement et 2000
2014 très bien en 2015
ça promet d'être un très bon millésime
un été ensoleillé quelques pluies de
temps à autre et une attention
particulière c'est la recette d'un
cocktail réussi pour un vin qui
pourraient être prometteur mais
attention il faut rester vigilant on va
continuer à enlever quelques feuilles
puis après on alternera avec des
dégustations de raisin pour voir
justement la maturité des pépins goûter
les pépins voir s'ils sont très tannique
peu pour voir s'ils sont bien mûres bien
mûres ou pas quoi installé depuis 1987
abonnés christophe s'est lancé dans
l'appellation bourgueil
et ces dernières années dans une
production bio il a pu déguster
quelques-uns des meilleurs millésimes de
loire je suis en train de me remémorer
ce que tu es le millésime 2005 puisque
c'était un très très bon millésime de
loire ça permet de
d'avoir le millésime en tête sa typicité
et puis d'imaginer ce que pourrait être
un millésime 2015 qui sera lui je pense
avec l'identité le world plus forte
qu'en 2005 une excellente année pour les
vins de loire
mais prudence une vendange n'ai fait que
lorsqu'elle est dans la cuve parole de
vignerons